If you listen, people will take you
where they want to go with a
conversation because most people haven't
had someone just listen to them really
for like more than 10 minutes ever in
their life. Your job isn't to lead, it's
to follow.
>> This is some of the most beautiful
advice on conversation that I have ever
heard. And what is crazy is that this
silent superpower is so easy to miss
even though it regularly has people open
up in just a few minutes.
>> How did she change it?
>> She has brought out the absolute best in
me like in in just about every way. like
didn't think we were going to go here.
Um, your mother left your father.
>> She escaped when I was about 4 months
old. So, it was, you know, bad before
that. And then, uh, yeah.
>> Have you spoken about this before?
>> No. I don't know. I I like you.
>> And I can confirm firsthand how powerful
Steven's presence is since a similar
thing happened with me. though later in
our conversation. So, in this video, I
want to break down Steven's hidden
conversational skill set and how you can
use it to connect with anyone,
especially if you're a naturally quiet
person. So, first, Steven almost never
interrupts, which is wildly different
from most conversations where people
interrupt all the time to correct you,
switch topics, or crack a joke.
>> How did we get social media wrong? Cuz
we were so optimistic. It's going to
connect with our friends. We're going to
join like-minded communities. And it it
to be fair it did do those does some of
that.
>> It does some of those things. But I want
to take you back. So in 2013 I was at
Google. I was a lot younger.
>> You're supposed to use an old timey
voice. Do that.
>> Now there's nothing wrong with a more
banterfilled style of conversation. But
if your goal is deep connection, giving
people space to 100% complete their
thoughts is the fast track. Now there is
an important exception to this rule.
Steven will interrupt if it takes the
other person deeper into their emotions.
So, if someone speeds through an
emotional story, he'll pause them to get
more information.
>> I I worked hard at school, mostly cuz I
just didn't want my dad to be upset with
me, which was uh the main driver for
most of my achievement in my career. And
I was very very sad um at that point in
my life. And so, it was very much like I
didn't I always hoped I wouldn't wake up
the next day. Um and
>> you mean that
>> truly
>> you really mean that? 100%.
100% cuz I remember when I was looking
at
>> or if someone mentions something
emotionally charged, he'll show that
he's curious to know more. I have done
roughly quarterly psychedelic journeys
for the last couple of years.
>> Why are you doing it?
>> Why am I doing it?
>> Honest answers only.
>> To connect with my heart. It has helped
me address the barriers to that, the
shame, and we didn't go super deep today
into it, but the things that I've
alluded to in my past that I thought
made me broken or unworthy of showing up
fully.
>> Where did that come from?
>> Yeah.
When you slow down to dig deeper, it
signals that you do care, that the other
person can get vulnerable without you
pulling away. And it's this combination
of wide open space plus emotional
digging that draws people into their
deeper vulnerabilities.
>> Had that sense of impending doom and I
didn't know how to make it go away. Um
>> I kind of asked this question earlier,
but was there an was there a moment
where you found out what was wrong?
>> Yeah. when I was about eight. Um
I
it's quite like a complex like string of
events that happened but basically it
had like met its like peak.
>> Now when this happens you want to follow
our next point which is to offer the
least invasive support possible. For
instance here Steven has opened the
topic of Kevin Olir's mother which gets
him emotional. She didn't. Yeah, there
she is. Geette.
So,
from this point on, Steven sits in
silence for 3 minutes while Kevin
processes grief, shares a story about
her, and then moves on to another topic.
This is completely opposite to what most
people do because when most people are
around an upset person, they do
everything they can to stop that person
from feeling upset, which just has the
effect of shutting them down. Now, if
you do want to support someone with your
words, just remember this tip. In highly
emotional moments, say less. Long
stories about how everything's going to
be okay can be well intended, but it
takes people out of their emotional
process. Using fewer words gives people
the chance to process their emotion in
your presence. And you can see that as
Francis Enanu touches on the death of
his young son Kobe. It's fewer words
that invite him back into his feeling.
>> Was the purpose of fighting if
I end up not being able to fight for the
only person that I can fight for?
Let's talk about something else.
>> Yeah. I'm sorry.
You can also watch how saying less in
the form of a question allows Gary Vee
to touch on the core of what his mother
means to him.
>> So if this were, God forbid, the last
day you had on earth to to send a
message to your mother, what exactly
would you say?
>> You did it. I would just say she did it.
What did she do?
>> She made me happy. Now, sometimes people
will have a really hard time in these
emotional moments. And if your instinct
says that even more support would be
helpful, physical touch is a superpower
here. And it doesn't need to be rushed.
>> It's okay. Take your time.
>> I'm going to come and give you a hug. I
feel really compelled to give you a hug.
I actually did a whole video on how to
calm someone's nervous system through
touch, but in short, you want to meet
them on their level, touch hearttoheart,
and hold a hug longer than normal
without the energy of trying to change
or fix them just to be with them.
>> Do you have a tissue?
>> Thanks.
you get nice hugs.
>> So remember, when people get emotional,
they do not need you to do anything to
get them out of it. If you just stay
present with them, that is often the
greatest gift. And when someone has
processed a big emotion or shared a
vulnerable story, it can be really
beautiful to use our next point, which
is to offer them an empathetic mirror.
This means that you reflect the
emotional core of what they've said back
to them in your own words.
>> We've been through, you know, something
that kind of unifies you, I think, as a
family, you know, can really solidify
you as a family. So, um, we're very
lucky.
>> You know, throughout this conversation,
I've really got a sense that this person
is your rock.
>> Totally.
>> And you'll know you've done a good job
when the other person enthusiastically
agrees with how you phrased things.
>> She changed your life.
>> Yeah, for sure. Or not. Now, this may
sound easy, but how often do you find
that you're trying to summarize what
someone has said only to have them
reply, "No, that's not what I meant."
The trick here is to not anticipate what
they're going to say next. It's to
encapsulate and repeat what has already
been shared. Anticipation comes from the
head and it's based on your past
experiences with other people.
Encapsulation comes from the heart and
it is based in the present conversation
that you're having. So this is what
anticipation looks like.
>> You basically saying women need to just
accept they're never going to make it on
equal terms, equal outcomes is what how
you defined it.
>> No, I didn't.
>> If I was a young woman watching that, I
would go, well, I might as well just go
and play with my Cindy dolls.
>> And this is summarization via empathetic
mirroring.
>> I remember the first time I watched
Jungle Book with him and I'm looking
over and seeing the joy he had watching
that movie. It was like, oh my god. But
I remember how I felt when I saw The
Jungle Book.
>> He saved you in many respects, didn't
he?
>> Without question. Without question.
Yeah.
>> Now, there is one more thing before we
get to our final point. If you implement
these tips in everyday conversation,
people will still just talk about
sports, the weather, or how busy things
are at work. You won't deeply connect.
So, you need a way to snap people out of
normal, superficial small talk. How?
Well, an excellent way to do that is by
asking chunky questions. These are
questions that instantly drive people
into meaningful conversation. And here
are just some examples that Steven uses.
>> So, if this were, God forbid, the last
day you had on earth to to send a
message to your mother, what exactly
would you say? What lessons did
fatherhood teach you about life and how
we should be living? What is your
deepest fear?
[Music]
>> Now, if you ask these questions out of
the blue, it will be a bit strange. So,
a great segue that you can use is, "Hey,
I heard this really awesome question
that I want to ask you that gets people
excited to answer nearly every time."
And it takes us to our final point. The
subtle power behind every one of these
tips is your presence. That is the
ability to let your attention rest with
someone else, to drop your own agenda
and allow them to lead while you follow
with gentle curiosity. This is hard.
There's always a temptation to prove our
worth in conversation, to be funny or
helpful, and to be seen and appreciated
for it. We tend to focus on how we are
coming across rather than inviting the
other person to share themselves. So
today, I want to leave you with a
challenge straight from Steven. Give
someone 10 minutes of your fully
attentive listening. To start it off,
you can lead with a chunky question and
then just use all the guidelines in this
video. If you give that a try, you will
probably be shocked with how deep a
connection you can form in a short
period of time. And obviously, this
listening isn't the only thing that
matters in social skills and
conversation. Your ability to express
yourself confidently also has a big
impact. So, if you do want to transform
your personal magnetism and your
charisma in the fastest way possible,
you may be interested in Charisma
University. People who have done our
30-day program have gotten promotions.
They've started dating new partners and
developed closer relationships with
their family and their friends. And if
that all sounds like something that
you'd be interested in, you can click
the link on screen to check out Charisma
University.